SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLEY. DODD DURAZZO.
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NHIÀU BOCOBO. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
SENATORS HAVE. WE CAN RETURN TO
OUR DESK. SENATORS AND GUESTS
BEHIND THE ROW, PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER BY SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER WHICH
STAY. STAY STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. SO WE
REMEMBER WE'RE ALWAYS IN THE
PRESENCE OF HOLY MYSTERY. COME,
O LIFE GIVING SPIRIT, TRANSFORM
US. STIR UP IN US THE FLAME OF
LOVE, WHICH IS YOUR GIFT. GIVE
US WISDOM TO SEE AS YOU SEE.
GIVE US UNDERSTANDING TO HEAR AS
YOU HEAR. GIVE US COURAGE AND
STRENGTH TO WALK THE WAY OF
JUSTICE AND INTEGRITY. KINDLE IN
US WONDER AND ALL THAT WE MAY
HAVE GRATEFUL SPIRITS. YOU WHO
DWELL WITHIN US. PRAYING
UNCEASINGLY. FILL US WITH LOVE
AND DEVOTION. HOLY WISDOM, GUIDE
US IN THE CHOICES WE MUST MAKE.
GIVE US DISCERNING HEARTS THAT
WE MAY CHOOSE WHAT IS GOOD IN
ACCORDANCE WITH YOUR DESIRE. AND
LOVING GOD OF MERCY, FINISH IN
US THE WORK YOU HAVE BEGUN.
AMEN. AMEN PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG FOR THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SENATE RULE 55 WILL
BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW GUESTS ON
THE FLOOR FOR TODAY'S FLOOR
SESSION. WE'RE STARTING OFF WITH
TWO ITEMS UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. SENATOR ASHBY WILL
HAVE THE FIRST INTRODUCTION FROM
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. SHE
IS PREPARED AND CAN BEGIN WHEN
SHE'S. SHE CAN. THANK YOU. MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS. IT'S MY
HONOR TO INTRODUCE AND RECOGNIZE
A HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL STAR
FROM SHELDON HIGH SCHOOL IN MY
DISTRICT. JAY WOODARD. JADEN IS
AN OUTSTANDING STUDENT ATHLETE
FOR THE HUSKIES IN SACRAMENTO'S
DELTA LEAGUE, WHICH IS ONE OF
OUR MOST COMPETITIVE LEAGUES,
ESPECIALLY FOR BASKETBALL IN
THIS REGION. AS A SENIOR, HE WAS
NAMED THE DELTA LEAGUE PLAYER OF
THE YEAR AND WAS FIRST TEAM ALL
SACRAMENTO, AVERAGING 17 POINTS
AND EIGHT REBOUNDS PER GAME,
LEADING HIS TEAM TO AN 11 ONE
RECORD IN LEAGUE PLAY. JADEN IS
ALSO AN ACCOMPLISHED STUDENT,
EARNING THE SCHOLAR ATHLETE
AWARD FROM SHELDON HIGH AND A
NATIONAL SCHOLAR ATHLETE AWARD
FROM THE ARMY RESERVE. HE IS
JOINED BY HIS DAD, BRUCE, ALSO A
BASKETBALL PLAYER AND A MEMBER
OF SACRAMENTO STATE'S ATHLETIC
HALL OF FAME. MOM MAHIRA,
SISTERS JAYLA AND BRITTANY
BRITTANY, ALSO A BASKETBALL
PLAYER WITH OAKLAND SWISH OF THE
WNBA, AND IS THE HEAD GIRLS
VARSITY BASKETBALL COACH AT
SAINT FRANCIS HIGH SCHOOL HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND A VERY
FAMILIAR FACE TO ALL OF YOU, MR.
NICK HARDIMAN, JAYDEN'S COUSIN
AND SOMEONE WE ALL KNOW AND LOVE
DEEPLY. Kò COLLEAGUES, PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING JAYDEN AS
AN OUTSTANDING STUDENT ATHLETE
FROM THE SACRAMENTO REGION.
WELCOME BASKETBALL STAR.
IF ANYONE WISHES TO TAKE A PHOTO
WITH THE NEXT NBA STAR, NOW IS
THE TIME. AFTER THIS PHOTO.
OUR NEXT INTRODUCTION IS GOING
TO BE FROM SENATOR CORTEZ. FROM
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU MAY BEGIN
YOUR INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND SENATORS,
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO RECOGNIZE
SHREEK WORK. GALGIANI GOSWAMI
FOR HIS VISIONARY SPIRITUAL
LEADERSHIP AND REMARKABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND. HAILING
FROM A FAMILY WITH A RICH
SPIRITUAL HERITAGE, HE WAS
CALLED TO SERVE HIS FAITH AT A
VERY YOUNG AGE. TODAY HE IS
RENOWNED FOR HIS SERVICE AS A
SPIRITUAL, SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
LEADER WHO HAS INSPIRED
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE, EXEMPLIFYING
LOVE, UNITY, COMPASSION AND
AFFECTION. HE HAS SERVED AS A
GUIDING FORCE FOR DISADVANTAGED
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY THROUGH HIS
LEADERSHIP IN ESTABLISHING AND
SUPPORTING NUMEROUS HUMANITARIAN
ORGANIZATIONS AND INSTITUTIONS,
HE'S BEEN HONORED WITH NUMEROUS
ACCOLADES FOR HIS WORK AND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO ECONOMIC AND
SPIRITUAL RESEARCH, RECEIVING AN
HONORARY DOCTORATE FROM AZTEC
UNIVERSITY OF NORTH AMERICA FOR
HIS EXTENSIVE PHILOSOPHIC AND
RELIGIOUS WRITINGS, AND BEING
APPOINTED AS DIRECTOR OF
SPIRITUAL SERVICES FOR THE SAARC
NATIONS INTERNATIONAL HUMAN
RIGHTS ASSOCIATION. I'D LIKE TO
COMMEND SHRI QUIRK-SILVA GOSWAMI
FOR HIS INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTION
TO SOCIAL, CULTURAL, SPIRITUAL,
EDUCATIONAL AND HUMANITY DRIVEN
ACTIVITIES AND THAT HE BE
EXTENDED, SINCERE, BEST WISHES
FOR CONTINUED HEALTH AND
HAPPINESS IN ALL HIS FUTURE
ENDEAVORS. HE'S A SHINING
EXAMPLE OF THE GREAT GOOD THAT
CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED BY BEING A
COMPASSIONATE AND CARING
INDIVIDUAL. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR MEANINGFUL SERVICE AND
DEDICATION TO THE COMMUNITY.
PLEASE WELCOME THEM. WELCOME TO
OUR SPECIAL GUEST.
STILL HAVE TO WATCH THIS.
SKINNER.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WERE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WERE DEEMED READ. AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
MOTIONS. RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE 29.10 B,
THE FOLLOWING BILLS WERE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. FILE ITEM NUMBER 147, AB
81. MAJORITY LEADER GONZALEZ,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MEMBERS. I
MOVED THE ADOPTION OF AMENDMENTS
AS APPROVED BY SENATE LEADERSHIP
THAT CROSSED THE DESK ON FRIDAY
THROUGH SUNDAY, JUNE 21ST
THROUGH 23RD, 2024. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED AND
PUBLISHED. SEN. JONES. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. YES, MADAM
PRESIDENT, A POINT OF
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY. PLEASE
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A POINT OF
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY. IF I MAY
STATE YOUR INQUIRY. THANK YOU.
WOULD THE MOTION MAKER BE ABLE
TO TELL US WHAT BILLS ARE ON
THAT LIST THAT WILL BE
CONSIDERED OVER THE WEEKEND?
MAJOR LEADER, WOULD YOU TAKE
THAT QUESTION? WE ARE. YES.
WELL, WE'RE GOING AHEAD TO
PROVIDE BUDGET AND BILL ITEMS,
BUT NOT AT THIS MOMENT. WE WILL
GIVE THAT AT A LATER DATE.
SENATOR JONES, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER AND WOULD ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS MOTION. SEEING NO
OTHER FURTHER DISCUSSION,
SENATOR GONZALEZ IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR JONES IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. MISS, MR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
DALLEY. NÓ. DODD AYE. TERRAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. GROVE HURTADO. AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO
NILO. NO. OKOBO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. ALVARADO.
GILL BRADFORD. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DORADO GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
LIMÓN. AYE OCHOA. BOGUE AYES 29.
NOS SIX. THE MOTION CARRIES.
CONTINUING STILL UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR UMBERG,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. PLEASE REMOVE
FILE NUMBER 165 AB 1824 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. THE
DEATHS WERE NO. COLLEAGUES WERE
JUST GETTING A LITTLE TOO LOUD.
SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS, PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR CHAPTER OUT
AMENDMENTS AB 2270 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AB 2581 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
AB 2073 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. THANK YOU. THE DESK
HAS NOTED. SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. WOULD WE PLEASE, AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, MOVE
FILE ITEM 149 ACR 182 BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DIXON TO
INACTIVE. PLEASE THE DESK. AS
NOTED, SENATOR HURTADO, THANK
YOU. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE AB 2225,
WHICH IS FILE NUMBER 138 FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE DESK
HAS NOTED SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
YES. THANK YOU. AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE
FILE ITEM 153 AB 3284 FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, AND PLEASE
MOVE IT TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE DESK HAS NOTED. SENATOR
SKINNER, THANK YOU. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, COULD WE
PLEASE PULL AB 2694 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR CHAPTER AMENDS? THE
DESK HAS NOTED AND SEE NOTHING
FURTHER. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. WE HAVE ITEMS ONE THROUGH
47 UNDER SECOND READING FILE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1893 WITH AMENDMENTS 2243,
WITH AMENDMENTS 2430, WITH
AMENDMENTS 28 AND 93, WITH
AMENDMENTS 544, WITH AMENDMENTS
2759. SECOND READING WILL BE
DEEMED READ. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
ITEMS 49 AND 51. UNDER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR
LAIRD IS PREPARED. PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM 49 IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF GALIT LIPA FOR
APPOINTMENT AS STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER. PRIOR TO THIS ROLE,
SHE WAS SERVING IN IN THE OFFICE
OF THE STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
INDIGENT DEFENSE IMPROVEMENT
DIVISION. SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE 5TH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. TERRAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA
B¢O. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. DALLEY
TORAZO. GLASER. AYE GROVE.
JONES. NGUYEN OAN. NILO. OKOBO
SATO. AYES 30 NOES ZERO.
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FOR
FILE ITEM 51. SENATOR LAIRD IS
ONCE AGAIN PREPARED. PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU AGAIN, MADAM
PRESIDENT. FINAL ITEM 51 IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF BARRY BROD AS A
MEMBER OF THE AGRICULTURE, LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD. PRIOR TO HIS
INITIAL APPOINTMENT IN 2019, HE
SERVED AS LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND WAS A
MANAGER MANAGING PARTNER AT
BROAD AND GUZMAN. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JUNE 5TH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE, NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO,
GILL ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ DALLI.
DODD. AYE. TERRAZZO. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO SKINNER A SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMMER.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN. ALVARADO. GIL.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY BARROSO.
GROVE. JONES NGUYEN. NILO. Ó
BOGUE. SATO AYES 30. NO. ZERO.
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED AND WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS UNDER SENATE.
THIRD READING. WE'RE GOING TO
START OFF WITH FILE ITEM 64. IF
SENATOR CABALLERO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 44 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO, RELATIVE TO PROBATION
SERVICES WEEK. SEN. CABALLERO.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SR 44,
WHICH WOULD RECOGNIZE PROBATION
OFFICER AWARENESS WEEK FOR FROM
JUNE 23RD THROUGH JUNE 29TH.
PROBATION PROFESSIONALS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE VITAL COMPONENTS
OF OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
COMMUNITIES. THEY FACILITATE
TRANSFORMATIVE REHABILITATION
AND EVIDENCE BASED INTERVENTIONS
TO GUIDE JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS TOWARD A HEALTHY, A
HEALTHIER, AND SAFER LIFE
TRAJECTORY. WE ASK PROBATION
OFFICERS TO ACT AS LINCHPINS
WITHIN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. THEY
EFFECTIVELY LEVERAGE RESOURCES
ACROSS VARIOUS SECTORS,
INCLUDING COURTS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, SOCIAL SERVICES,
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION TO
SUPPORT REHABILITATION EFFORTS
TO PREVENT RECIDIVISM. PROBATION
OFFICERS UNDERGO COMPREHENSIVE
TRAINING TO ADDRESS THE DIVERSE
NEEDS OF JUSTICE INVOLVED.
INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS MANAGE
TRAUMA, ADDICTIONS, LOSS, AND
OTHER CHALLENGES. FACILITATING
THE SAFE TRANSITION BACK INTO
THE COMMUNITY. CALIFORNIA'S
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS PRIORITIZE
POLICIES THAT PROMOTE EQUITY AND
INCLUSIVITY BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND BETTER THAN ANYONE
THAT NOT EVERYONE EXPERIENCES
THE SAME CHALLENGE. CHALLENGES
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENTS OF
CALIFORNIA PLAY A PIVOTAL ROLE
IN ENHANCING COMMUNITY SAFETY
COLLEAGUES BY ADDRESSING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME AND
REDUCING RECIDIVISM. RECIDIVISM.
THESE OFFICERS CONTRIBUTE TO A
SAFER ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. THEIR SUCCESS IS
INSTRUMENTAL IN FOSTERING
PROSPEROUS AND THRIVING
COMMUNITIES. AND ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL, THEY WERE VERY GOOD
PARTNERS. WHEN I WAS A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY AND HAD CLIENTS
WHO NEEDED THEIR SERVICES AND
WHO WERE, WHO NEEDED THEIR
SERVICES AND ALSO THEIR, THEIR
ASSISTANCE. PROBATION OFFICER
AWARENESS WEEK SERVES AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
APPRECIATE THE INVALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF PROBATION
PROFESSIONALS. I ENCOURAGE ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO JOIN IN
RECOGNIZING AND CELEBRATING THE
PROFOUND IMPACT OF PROBATION
SERVICES ON OUR COLLECTIVE
WELL-BEING, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL RIGHT. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR MEN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OKOBO. AYE PODIUM. AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
SATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMILED.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL.
DURAZZO. GROVE MENJIVAR.
PORTANTINO. AYE RUBIO. AYE AYES
35. NÓ ZERO. THE RESOLUTION
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
66 SEN. PADILLA IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION 16 BY SENATOR
PADILLA RELATIVE TO THE
CHUCKWALLA NATIONAL MONUMENT AND
THE JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL
MONUMENT. SENATOR PADILLA, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION 16,
WHICH URGES THE PRESIDENT TO USE
THE ANTIQUITIES ACT OF 1906 TO
ESTABLISH THE CHUCKWALLA
NATIONAL MONUMENT AND TO
ESTABLISH A NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE, MANAGED JOSHUA TREE
NATIONAL MONUMENT ADJACENT TO
THE JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK.
OUR CHANGING CLIMATE THREATENS
IMPORTANT CULTURAL SITES AND
FRAGILE ECOSYSTEMS, AND WE MUST
DO ALL WE CAN TO PROTECT THEM.
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
FIRST PEOPLE, SOVEREIGN NATIONS
IN MY DISTRICT AND COOPERATION
WITH REGIONAL AND NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WORKING TO
DESIGNATE THE CHUCKWALLA
NATIONAL MONUMENT AND TO EXPAND
JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK TO
CONSERVE EXCEPTIONAL PUBLIC
DESERT LANDS. THIS DESIGNATION
WOULD PROTECT APPROXIMATELY
627,000 ACRES, REACHING WEST
FROM THE COACHELLA VALLEY REGION
TO THE EAST NEAR THE COLORADO
RIVER, AND ALSO PROPOSES TO
PROTECT APPROXIMATELY 17,000
ACRES OF PUBLIC LANDS THAT ARE
ADJACENT TO THE EAST SIDE OF THE
JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK.
PERMANENT PROTECTING THESE
PUBLIC LANDS IS A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY THAT WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY ADVANCED, STATE
AND FEDERAL 30 BY 30 GOALS AND
WOULD ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS IN
NATURE FOR A COMMUNITY THAT IS
IN DIRE NEED OF IT. THROUGH THIS
DESIGNATION, WE CAN ALSO HONOR
THE CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE THESE
LANDS REPRESENT FOR THE TRIBAL
SOVEREIGN NATION NATIONS THAT
CALL THIS PLACE HOME, THE
CAHUILLA, THE KI¾M, HèA, VÌ, THE
MOJAVE, THE KITCHEN, AND SERRANO
NATIONS. THESE LANDS ARE ALSO A
LIVING LANDSCAPE WITH
INTERCONNECTED CULTURAL,
NATURAL, AND SPIRITUAL
SIGNIFICANCE WHICH SUSTAINS,
WHICH SUSTAINS THE WELL-BEING
AND SURVIVAL OF INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE TODAY. MEMBERS, PLEASE
JOIN ME IN URGING THE PRESIDENT,
URGING, EXCUSE ME, THE
PRESIDENT, TO UTILIZE HIS
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH THE
CHUCKWALLA NATIONAL MONUMENT AND
TO ESTABLISH NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE MANAGED JOSHUA TREE
NATIONAL MONUMENT ADJACENT TO
THE JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK,
DOING SO WILL ALLOW US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THESE
LANDS FASTER, WHILE WE WAIT FOR
CONGRESS TO OFFICIALLY
INCORPORATE THE LAND INTO THE
PARK. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. WE HAVE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DORADO EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OKOBO. AYE
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO BY SATO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN. RODA-GIL. DALLI DURAZZO.
GROVE JONES. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE. AYES 34. NÓ ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING ON
TO ITEM 151 UNDER ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING. THE MAJORITY
LEADER IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 2006 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. CERVANTES. RELATIVE TO
IMMIGRANT HERITAGE MONTH.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF
THE LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS,
IT'S MY HONOR TO PRESENT S ACR
2006 RECOGNIZING THE MONTH OF
JUNE AS IMMIGRANT HERITAGE
MONTH. THIS RESOLUTION IS A
REMINDER AND A CELEBRATION OF
THE IMPORTANT ROLE IMMIGRANTS
PLAY IN OUR SOCIETY AND THE
IMPORTANT IMPACT THEY HAVE ON
OUR GREAT STATE AND NATION.
IMMIGRANTS COMPRISE MORE THAN
35% OF CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
ACCOUNT FOR OVER TWO THIRDS OF
ALL AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. NEARLY
ONE HALF OF WORKERS IN THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY, AND 57%
OF ALL SOFTWARE DEVELOPERS.
CALIF WAS RICH. HISTORICAL
TAPESTRY WAS BUILT BY IMMIGRANTS
OF ALL LANDS. IMMIGRANT
HOUSEHOLDS MAKE UP 28% OF THE
TOTAL HOUSEHOLD INCOME IN
CALIFORNIA, AND CONTRIBUTE $715
BILLION OF CALIFORNIA'S GROSS
DOMESTIC PRODUCT AND $26 BILLION
IN STATE AND LOCAL TAXES. I'M
PROUD TO SERVE IN A STATE THAT
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT ROLE
IMMIGRANTS PLAY IN OUR SOCIETY
AND THAT CONTINUES TO BE
INCLUSIVE, COMPASSIONATE AND
SUPPORTIVE OF ALL IMMIGRANTS WHO
YEARN FOR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
WE MUST ALWAYS CONTINUE FIGHTING
FOR A PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP FOR
ALL IMMIGRANT WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES, AND PROVIDE LIFE
SAVING RELIEF THROUGH PROGRAMS
THAT ENSURE FOOD SECURITY,
HEALTH CARE, AND PROVIDE A
SAFETY NET FOR ALL. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING ACR 2006. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR MINH,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND SENATORS, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS, I RISE IN PROUD SUPPORT
OF AC 2006, ACR 2006 RECOGNIZING
IMMIGRATION HERITAGE MONTH
THROUGHOUT THE MONTH, WE'RE
WORKING ALL TO EDUCATE AND
INFORM COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE GOLDEN STATE ABOUT THE
UNIQUE AND DIVERSE IMMIGRANT
STORIES THAT HAVE HELPED SHAPE
OUR CULTURE, SOCIETY, AND
NATION. OF COURSE, THIS IS A
COUNTRY OF IMMIGRANTS IN THE
UNITED STATES. TODAY, 13.8% OF
AMERICAN RESIDENTS ARE FOREIGN
BORN IMMIGRANTS. 7% OF THOSE ARE
OF ASIAN DESCENT. AND OF COURSE,
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE
QUITE A LOT OF IMMIGRANTS AS
WELL. OUR IMMIGRANT POPULATION
MAKES UP ALMOST 27% OF OUR TOTAL
POPULATION, 15.5% OF OUR
POPULATION IDENTIFIES AS ASIAN.
IMMIGRANTS HAVE PLAYED A LARGE
ROLE IN OUR NATION AND OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY, MAKING UP 23%
OF ENTREPRENEURS, 23% OF STEM
WORKERS, AND 16% OF NURSES IS
ASIAN. IMMIGRANTS HAVE
REMARKABLY CONTRIBUTED TO
AMERICAN SOCIETY. THEY'RE THE
VISUAL, PERFORMING AND CULINARY
ARTS AND MORE. AND I JUST WANT
TO TAKE A POINT OF PRIVILEGE
HERE AND EXPRESS AT A TIME WHEN,
UNFORTUNATELY, IMMIGRATION IS
UNDER ATTACK, WHEN THE VALUES OF
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY Kò SEEM UP
FOR GRABS. I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT WE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WELCOME IMMIGRANTS.
WE VALUE IMMIGRANTS AND
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE TO DO
MORE TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
IMMIGRANTS FEEL LIKE THEY BELONG
HERE. THEY ARE LOVED HERE, AND
THAT WE ARE DOING MORE TO
PROMOTE THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE CORE
AMERICAN VALUES THAT HAVE
BROUGHT SO MANY IMMIGRANTS,
INCLUDING MY PARENTS, TO THIS
COUNTRY. I IT'S IMPORTANT WE
CONTINUE TO REPRESENT AND
CELEBRATE THE DIVERSE HISTORIES
AND CONTRIBUTIONS IMMIGRANTS
HAVE MADE IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU IN JOINING
THE AAPI CAUCUS IN SUPPORTING
ACR 206. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SENATOR GONZALEZ, YOU
MAY CLOSE. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE FOR HIS
REMARKABLE WORDS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
I'LL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPERM AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE DODD. AYE. DORADO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE NILO. AYE. OKOBO AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GILL. BRADFORD
AYE. DORADO. GROVE. MCGUIRE AYE.
PADILLA AYE. UMBERG. AYE. AYES
36. NOES ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR, WE HAVE ITEMS
154 THROUGH 189. IS THERE ANY
MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILL
2325 1900 1948, 2049, 2287, TWO,
95, 32, 88, 32, 89, 24, 74,
1782, 1870, 1903, 1929, 1936,
1974, 1988, 2018 2129, 22, 27,
22, 75, 22, 99, 25, 56, 25, 70,
27, OH EIGHT, 27, 31, 27, 70,
20, 70, 27, 71, 29, 32, 31, OH
FIVE. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 147. ASSEMBLY BILL
375 1966. SENATE BILL 1127 1525.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
152 166 193 1941 95. I THINK
THAT WAS ONE BREATH. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
FIRST ITEM. ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN. I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMILED. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN.
ALVARADO. GIL. RAZO GROVE.
JONES. AYE. AYES 36 NOES ZERO.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. WE
HAVE A SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
TODAY. ITEMS 190 THROUGH 190. WE
DID IT ALL TOGETHER. WE DON'T
HAVE ANOTHER ITEM. WE'RE MOVING
ON TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR LAIRD, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN THE
SWING SPACE IN ROOM 1100. AFTER
ADJOURNMENT, SENATORS MANUEL
CUEVAS, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. THE JOINT
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE WILL MEET
IN ROOM 1100 UPON ADJOURNMENT.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE, COLLEAGUES.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE. MAJORITY
LEADER, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
MEMBERS. WE WILL HAVE A SHORT
DEM CAUCUS SHORTLY AFTER SESSION
TODAY IN THE MADI LOUNGE. IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THE SENATORS WANT TO
LEAVE. EXACTLY. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I HOPE EVERYONE HAS
ENJOYED A RELAXING, CALM WEEK
THIS WEEK AND IF YOU LIKE A
RELAXING, CALM WEEK THIS WEEK,
THEN NEXT WEEK WILL BE EVEN
BETTER. THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY, JUNE
24TH AT 2 P.M. THANKS FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK, MADAM PRESIDENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY,
JUNE 24TH AT 2 P.M.